70% of why you weigh what you weigh can
be explained by genetics and this is out
of Dr Robert plowman's book blueprint
now this isn't to say if you get born on
a desert island where there's no food
guess what you're going to be thin but
on average 70% of your BMI correlates
with your parents the way that they've
been able to do this is by doing uh twin
studies that are separated at Birth so
you manag to keep the genetics the same
but put them into different environments
what percent do you think this is
influenced by genetics eye color 100%
95% height 100% 85% % how is height 80%
is that also like your diet of course
how well fed are you how well rested are
you I think sleep correlates with height
actually quite significantly most
definitely so are you saying I could
theoretically be taller had I eaten
better and slept more but what if I did
both of those perfectly and I still end
up at the do you think then I would be
even shorter yeah maybe you might be at
the upper bracket of exactly how tall
you can be